what's going on rob this is guys and
this video is brought to you by nelson
and murdoch attorneys at law so nelson
and murdoch is a general practice law
firm located in hell's kitchen new york
and seeking an entry-level litigation
attorney with one to three years of
litigation experience with a focus and
interest in family law now their firm
culture acknowledges and supports
work-life balance while also providing
high quality work and commitment to
excellence for their clients and the
right candidate will have a drive to
build and expand their family law
litigation practice with nelson and
murdock so if you're looking to get into
family law make sure you guys check out
the link down in the description but
with that said let's get into it what's
going on guys this is rob and
technically i decided to record one of
these videos even though i don't really
know whether or not you guys actually
want to see it uh but villains we need
in the mcu i want to talk about a
nihilist here right annihilus is a
villain we need in the marvel cinematic
universe and here's a reason why so
introducing annihilus will do two things
of the marvel cinematic universe the
first thing it'll do is actually expand
the nature of the mcu and really even
the multiverse kind of give us more of
that landscape than we had before and
the second would show just how bad
things could get in the universe itself
so here's one thing to understand
annihilus had been around for a long
long time in marvel comics and then we
eventually got the annihilation event
back in 2006. so kind of focusing on the
nature of annihilus for a second he
comes from a place called the negative
zone now this is the expanding of the
marvel cinematic universe landscape that
i was talking about so what you have is
you have like the multiverse right an
infinite number of universes that exist
out there but you have some places where
only one of them exists across the
entirety of the multiverse so these are
places like the dimension of manifest
stations those of you guys who don't
know what that means in mobile comics
the cosmic entities don't actually have
a physical form right they're basically
ideas right so it's like the idea of you
going to get something to eat it doesn't
have a physical form the food you eat
represents the the idea that you had but
it's not the actual idea itself and so
when the cosmic entities want to take on
a physical form what they do is they
travel to the dimension of
manifestations and they meet with a
being called anthropomorpho and what
anthropomorpho does is he gives them
what's called an m body basically a
physical form they can they can put
their essence into and then appear i
mean if things are bad enough they can
just will themselves a physical form but
more often than not they go to the
dimension of manifestations at least
according to the old quasar stories from
back in the early 1990s but the
important thing here is a place like the
dimension of manifestations a place like
the far shore right so basically where
the one above all resides things like
that and then the negative zone there's
only ever one of them across the
multiverse so the thing about the
negative zone is that it's basically a
giant hallway of doors right so any
universe can enter into the negative
zone so it's entirely possible that the
marvel cinematic universe that like some
characters from the mcu could enter into
the negative zone and then like andrew
garfield happens to be there andrew
garfield is not from the mar the main
marvel cinematic universe he's from his
own universe but his universe has access
to the negative zone how it is andrew
garfield ended up there i don't know and
honestly we probably wouldn't care
we would just be ecstatic to see him
again but the negatives zone itself
houses like an entire universe right
there's planets and their solar systems
and all kinds of stuff but it's all
basically ruled by annihilus and the
annihilation wave annihilus has what's
called the cosmic control rod this is
basically an artifact that allows him to
manipulate cosmic energy it is by all
standards of measurement the negative
zone equivalent of the power cosmic or
the power that galactus has which is
actually how he was able to defeat
galactus during the annihilation event
but the important thing here is that
when it comes to this place the
annihilation wave
as crazy as it sounds is literally just
a giant army of bugs
i'm not even lying to you right it's
just trillions upon trillions of bucks
and that may seem laughable but when the
annihilation event took place and
annihilus and the entire annihilation
wave basically broke out of the negative
zone and invaded the main marvel
universe oh it was nuts all bets were
off literally the story opened with like
star-lord and nova richard ryder who
were leading like this united something
front or whatever i can't remember
exactly what it was called they were
basically refugees like what they were
doing is they were going from world to
world and just trying to save people
gathering them up and just taking them
back to like some place they were
basically just falling back it's all
they were just retreating trying to like
not die because the annihilation wave
had just shown up in the universe and
spread like a plague like they took out
galactus i mean just it was it was
absolutely bonkers right they actually
started using galactus as a source of
power but by all standards of
measurement they would have won the
funny thing and the reason why none of
earth's superheroes were there is
because while annihilation was going on
civil war was happening and there's
actually a point where richard ryder
nova shows up on earth and it's like
what are you even doing like the
universe is being consumed by an army of
bugs and you're bickering over
superhuman registration
it was one of the funniest things like
he shows up on earth and like venom in
like the thunderbolts i try to attack
him like you're not registered he was
like that's the least of your concerns
right now right but like he didn't have
time to tell anybody what was going on
so he ultimately just had to like get
out of there before they just snatched
him up right so so literally he gets
back to star-lord and he was like so
earth isn't going to help us right those
numb skulls are bickering over
superhuman registration we're on our own
now eventually galactus is freed and
ultimately he ends up just annihilating
the entire annihilation wave or at least
so much of it that like the the event's
basically over and at that point is
cleanup duty but like the the threat of
annihilus is huge because what this
would do is is with him being a nihilist
right the belief that life is
meaningless and that kind of a thing he
would literally just kind of spread
throughout the whole universe thanos
blinking out half the life in the
universe that was really more of an
altruistic idea coming from a guy who
was basically a dick it's really all it
was i mean thanos i mean we can't no
one's gonna argue that right i mean
thanos was was a dick right he was like
i'm gonna blink out half the life of the
universe but his motivation for doing so
you could argue came from a good place
annihilus is not coming from a good
place he's not like a misunderstood
villain doing things for positive
reasons no he wanted to destroy all life
in the universe
and he would have done it had they not
rescued galactus and galactus just
obliterated the annihilation way like
it's that kind of a thing right this guy
cannot be redeemed there's no fixing him
there's no saving him there's no getting
him to become a good guy if he allies
with you it's because there's something
to be gained for like annihilus and the
annihilation wave it's just one of those
things so again i think it would be
awesome to see him
in the marvel cinematic universe because
it would give us this gravitas right it
would give us this idea beyond cain the
conqueror anyway that there are threats
that exist out there in other dimensions
that if they showed up in the mcu all
hell would break loose we got a kind of
taste of that when it came to dormammu
but we don't know the full totality of
what darmamu is capable of we know he's
like really powerful and we know the
dark dimension is a result of him
conquering some of the locales around
him but we don't know if the people in
those locales were all powerless or
anything like that our knowledge and
understanding of the power of dormammu
comes from the ancient one just being
like he's really powerful and our
knowledge in the comics and that's it we
actually haven't seen him do anything
right nothing significant i mean it'd
have been different if like during the
events of avengers in-game like all
hell's breaking loose like the avengers
are just getting crushed there's nothing
they can do and then dormammu shows up
snaps his fingers the gauntlet vanishes
thanos dies and he's like i'll catch you
all later and then leaves
it would have been different if it was
something like that by just giving us
this just stupid display of power but we
don't really know exactly what it is
that our mom was capable of more so than
that
outside of the cosmic control rod
annihilus doesn't necessarily have to
have that in order to be all-powerful it
helped during the events of annihilation
but we've seen him launch massive
campaigns and he's conquered huge
sections of the negative zone even
before he had the cosmic control rod and
so when you compare something like that
right a more tangible villain even
though he looks like a giant grasshopper
to something like dormammu who's a
falteen right just a being of pure
magical energy it would be a little more
cool to see a nihilist because if you
have someone who's just really capable
that could just punch him to death then
like annihilus would die like that would
basically be it but the sheer
overwhelming force of the annihilation
wave the fact that like all these
different superheroes that we could be
introduced to over the mcu right all
these characters that we didn't even
know existed quasar and different things
like that despite all their vaunted
power carol danvers captain marvel all
that kind of stuff there's nothing they
can do in the face of the annihilation
wave and it's not because each of these
insects all has reality warping powers
right or flight super speed or something
like that it's because there's just so
damn many of them right just trillions
upon trillions upon trillions of these
things that all just descend onto the
universe right it's it's like locust
descending onto your house right like
every locust in the world just descends
onto your local neighborhood what are
you gonna do there's nothing you can do
right you just flee for your life and
that's basically it so let me know if
you guys would be interested in seeing
somebody like annihilus in the mcu with
with disney owning the fox properties
the likelihood of us seeing him at some
point in time is insanely high the
question is would it be the annihilation
event would we basically see him showing
up in the universe for the purpose of
conquering it and almost succeeding
would we see that kind of thing take
place so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching i will catch you all later
peace